[Applause]
i have to say
of everything the chanting of conan
conan
i'm gonna miss that the most cause i'm
an egotistical son of a [ __ ] i'm a
crazy person
you guys can have a seat by the way
please they're all standing there like
yeah you were waiting for me to give
some kind of political address
we await your word on that sir
[Music]
crazy
i swear to god i said all of you go to
the 7-eleven rob for conan then i'll be
like
[Applause]
would you like a roller hot dog
[Laughter]
go to the program we got a uh well sorry
it's great it's getting weird i mean
it's nice
it's so many emotions it's our it's our
second to last uh program
yeah on tbs we're wrapping things up
here yeah we don't like emotions
yeah so we try and hide from them but
they're sneaking in
yeah because i'm so irish catholic i
keep saying to my wife
am i blocking my emotions
i'm not sure i feel enough about the
show ending am i blocking my emotions
uh we're having a lovely time here at
the largo theater lovely here
yeah it's our last one i did hear this
did you know this andy last uh last week
people were saying our show looked like
a high school theater production
well we heard your complaint we've made
some changes tonight is gonna look like
a community college
a very good community college now go to
7-eleven rob
rob
[Applause]
[Music]
no no it's bad
this is how q on got started don't do
that
people are getting this
i watched conan last night he gave the
sign of the sea
i must now move